une victoire qui pourrait devenir celle
de tous les chauffeurs de vtc la cour de
cassation a confirmé un arrêt rendu par
la cour d'appel de paris
il ya bien un lien de subordination
entre l'entreprise et l'ancien chauffeur
ce dernier peut donc être considéré
comme un salarié et non comme un
travailleur indépendant
le plaignant avait saisi la justice en
2017 bieber avait désactivé son compte
l'empêchant ainsi d'accéder à des
clients l'arrêt de la cour de cassation
marque donc un tournant dans les
relations entre les chauffeurs de vtc et
la plateforme de mise en relation
mais pour l'avocat de l'ancien chauffeur
ce n'est pas surprenant
il n'y avait aucun aucun doute c'était
pour moi une évidence mais de toute
façon ce sont les juges qui ont le
dernier mot et les juges conforte cette
analyse il existe bien contre un travail
puisque les critères du lien de
subordination sont tous remplis sont
tous réunis
l'ancien chauffeur du beurre peut
désormais demander un rappel de salaire
et des indemnités de rupture de contrat
cette requalification en contrat de
travail est une première pour hubert en
france elle pourrait bénéficier à
d'autres conducteurs affiliés à ce type
de plateforme et avoir des répercussions
sur leur modèle économique
c'est une démarche individuelle donc ça
va ça va dépendre du nombre de
chauffeurs qui décidera oui ou non
d'aller demander la requalification en
contrat de travail
donc aujourd'hui c'est trop tôt pour
dire quel va être l'impact sur le modèle
économique d'hubert en france ou à
l'étranger
150 chauffeurs auraient déjà lancé une
procédure aurait l'intention de le faire
en novembre 2018 la cour de cassation
avait confirmé l'existence d'un contrat
de travail entre une plateforme
numérique et un de ses agents elle avait
établi un lien de subordination entre
take it easy une société de livraison de
repas est l'un de ces coursiers je
propose d'écouter sayah baronne
secrétaire général du syndicat des
chauffeurs privés
c'est non je pense que cette décision
c'est un début de victoire pour les
chauffeurs et disons que pour les
longues procédures qui vont nous
attendre
ça va diminuer peut-être franchement le
délai quoi donc là ça fait plus de trois
ans déjà au niveau de nos procédures là
on commence à voir le bout du tunnel
et de toute manière en parallèle je
pense que tout le monde a vu que ces
pseudos économies dites collaborative
l'économie du numérique etc ne
fonctionne pas finalement donc il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes
chez nous ça a été très favorisés et
concilier par l'état ils ont voulu
vraiment cette économie là maintenant je
pense qu'on est arrivé au bout donc là
une décision extrêmement logique en fait
de la situation et d'économie quoi on
bien comprendre que la plupart ne
demanderont pas être totalement salariés
en fait il ya plusieurs cas de figure
vous avez une partie des chauffeurs qui
vous dit je travaille 60 à 70 heures par
semaine pour gagner entre 900 et 1200
euros net par mois
autant devenir salarié donc il est vrai
qu'il ya une partie qui est prête à
devenir salarié mais la plupart des
plaignants savait aussi pour dire
pendant x années
vous m'avez dominé vous vous êtes
comporté avec moi comme si j'étais votre
salarié
donc il va falloir passer à la caisse
donc finalement toutes ces années où la
plateforme à frauder le droit de ces
pseudo indépendant va devoir payer ces
années de fraude en fait
[Musique]